hey let's go bros Monday yeah okay
welcome back to outlast this is not live
like last time a lot of you guys really
love the lie alive episode how you doing
baby
shake that ass for me my leg alright
let's watch out for these [ __ ]
peasants ain't gonna get me this stuff I
don't understand we have to throw up on
me like why did I ever know you're
disgusting you're all disgusting No
alright let's just go through here
really quick
very nice there we go we were fine I was
gonna say a lot of people like the live
episode but the reason I did it was
because all my outlets videos got a
pretty monetize uncorrect Lee so I
wanted to see if I could stream to fix
it but it didn't seem like it made any
difference
so here we are back again my only friend
appreciate all your feedback it's all
good good [ __ ] alright I guess we'll go
in here I don't know where the [ __ ] to
go excellent
what the [ __ ] day what the [ __ ] is your
problem [ __ ] what the [ __ ] man what
did I ever do heal the shed is your
problem man you better stay in there boy
what is this [ __ ] place
maybe we can climb underneath we can
okay
batteries hell yeah mouth okay let's
take them [ __ ] go go go he's coming in
[ __ ] you skinny [ __ ] Oh what are you
gonna do then oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I
shouldn't have asked I shouldn't have
asked
I shouldn't have [ __ ] ass okay maybe
through here here we go you guys are you
you guys look great you don't just don't
[ __ ] touch me all right
what yeah boy see you later skinny
[ __ ] what is he doing that's right
best player about last of all time
you're watching the zero def playthrough
everyone that was love zero Depp's
everyone top of the mornin better
[Music]
okay well seriously nothing here
seriously [ __ ]
so I'm not supposed to be here ah come
on man of course we just had to [ __ ]
jump off I keep missing the most obvious
[ __ ] [ __ ] in this game I'm the worst
the worst player of this game hell of a
day
oh no what did I do oh my glasses where
am I
hey this is not so bad who's out there
who's creeping in the night let's go
this way
No shut up what a [ __ ] straight straight
straight straight straight
ah ah this man [ __ ] did he just say [ __ ]
me that's my line and also please do
and I'll never find us what are they oh
it's a little the [ __ ] is that ah oh oh
no oh no oh no oh no not here no no no
no no no no no no no you don't want to
come here bye
that's right [ __ ] you're that big maybe
can crawl through this tent yes am i
wearing my [ __ ] headphones backward
again I was like what the [ __ ] I keep
wearing these headphones wrong all right
let's just go we're good we're good
no don't touch me
[ __ ] eyepatch pirate some [ __ ]
soakin oh [ __ ] that's bad that's bad
that's fine I'll just go here why does
no one in this game like me
oh it's a spring here for [ __ ] sake I
always missed the obvious [ __ ]
Oh what this game is so [ __ ] weird
Jesus Christ all right let's go out hey
at top of the Jess Jessica come back to
me I love you you're my child that [ __ ]
she's such an [ __ ] what's happening
here I can't jump over this game is too
[ __ ] dark man I can't see anything
okay well I don't know why she's
whispering to me I don't need you to
tell me that we got Gunja and crunch aah
well what's up that's my shadow damn I
look buff don't I get that protein boy
yes that's how your computer all right
we got a father puts Porcari Feast of
the Blessed Virgin Mary I took miss gray
out of phys ed today to have a little
talk with her
okay running away huh
it just saved I don't know if I like
that ha yeah I'm on top of things if
this is a real horror game I I'd be fine
trust me trust me I'd be I'd be just
fine
and I'd have zero death that's for sure
that's for sure out of hand I wouldn't
have any dish ice up Jesus what you're
doing nice nipples gotta say he's got
abs juicers batteries when you have a
good tough front effluent oh that was
the worst batteries what would Jesus do
what would Jesus do everyone I don't
know what would Jesus do suck on my
nipples pellet pack what would Jesus do
he would go in this room and research
left in Jesus right Jesus he stole my
[ __ ] bag what was that some prince
over here breaths let's check it out
what do we got what's up a is the bear
hey it's nice lit surprise diarrhea
surprise
no diarrhea good game everyone but
perhaps game of the year even some would
say someone smidge [ __ ] on the walls
garden
goddamn it Jessica what did I say about
the [ __ ] Samarin what the [ __ ] Jessica
well then don't [ __ ] leave it is dumb
[ __ ] what someone just locked the door
all right Jessica it's time to go home
we're leaving the state and Jessica
we're never going back to IRAs Arizona
he's coming what is that what
stop doing that brush I mean games Adam
[ __ ] you know what you are I'm crawling
in a stump Pole a stump hole no don't
touch me don't touch me oh [ __ ] they got
me god damn it
oh no oh you [ __ ] tiny little [ __ ]
prophet now praise God why what do you
want me for it might seem that mortal
comic character visiting no know why I'm
infected
where's emini Bane or some [ __ ] okay
well that can be arranged no gospel the
sacred words of teaching
to cross and die he will be buried no
he'll rise again you know perfect flesh
eat of that flesh and hold community and
be healed of our physical sins and we
shall inherit this broken earth
everything it's all ready for you oh
great thanks guys appreciate it I had an
Airbnb booked those I can't make it
you're supposed to have a gospel for us
to guide us salvation after the end
[ __ ] guys so disgusting oh [ __ ] I'm
getting crucified that's cool how they
did that
that wasn't so bad why all right Nick we
got one more hand to go I would do it
but you know you oh [ __ ] he's got my
Sony
what is he thinking for down here there
is no suffering I do not deserve well
you are you are pretty girl is he gonna
kill himself no no no god damn [ __ ]
this is [ __ ] man discuss or sir
disgusting goddamn [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
alright here we go I have a feeling I
know what we're gonna do [ __ ] it out
well we don't have the camera anymore so
that's not very good that was like my
best friend in this [ __ ] game
[Music]
this game is so [ __ ] good I love how
they did this gotta stop bleeding I
can't see anything I can't see [ __ ]
anything is that the point cuz I can't
see anything
legit can't see okay and returned a
little bit top o the mornin to ya oh
[ __ ]
bandages if there any bandages around
here
perhaps we could climb this the answer
to that is no I don't see anything when
I oh here we go just anyone please have
some don't [ __ ] touch me
you guys are peasants ah why would you
why would you know who I am
well goddamn 7s 0 deaths every one zero
deaths that was a [ __ ] and I think
we both know that was [ __ ] I think
we both can agree on
nananananana don't look at me with those
eyes uh-huh
hey sexy
I think I got it I think I got it this
is easy look we'll go through here right
easy easy the game had it laid out for
me hey hey hey yeah alright let's go
let's go everybody we're doing great
we're doing great Bruce okay and look we
can go up there later but first let's
get the the bandages nevermind let's get
the [ __ ] out let's get the [ __ ] out
let's get vodka oh my hands hurts too
much
[ __ ] so I got to get the bandages after
all okay that's fine that's fine fives
fine
yeah it does hurt that does hurt the
beta just should take care of that
don't [ __ ] hurt me bad yes heal I
can't even heal what are you a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
there you go heal I should take care of
that boy don't need two of them maybe I
said oh look we had a little bit extra
you got a concern event yes
oh my watch broke and back it up back it
up back it up back it up cuz my ass is
looking good I'm backing the hell out of
there yeah that's the [ __ ] up [ __ ] up
bye-bye zero - everyone we're doing
great we're doing [ __ ] good I'm proud
of myself and you for not doing anything
as always ow
you could have warned me about that how
about that I want my camcorder back oh
god what is happening here oh they're
just looking for me
there's more people throwing up having a
good time it's just like good old
parties I have a feeling I should jump
down here but at the same time I don't
want it
that's what airport PA let's get a quick
hey all right we did it
cool that was a tricky part not really
if you knew how to do it oh geez they
hate me don't they I come in this way
can't top where are they
let's climb through the [ __ ] tent
good old tent [ __ ] I can't [ __ ] I'm
literally so [ __ ] if he finds me hey
god damn god damn okay how do I [ __ ]
this is a terrible idea
okay we're safe
batteriess bandage s hell yeah
on the mornings gun and it can't go on
nope
it's just Jeff I was supposed to die
well I hate to break it to you ah [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh great another dead end dead end
the video game you can't find me here oh
there it is syrtis let's go gross halli
am the best MLG player at this game I
told you I told you what I say that's
right I did say that as well ah yeah
what you gonna know you don't say
nothing you don't say nothing boy
where is it saving oh yeah horse
shooting me okay
I was supposed to hide there got it
where is he going
[Applause]
I don't like him I don't like him very
much are we just gonna follow him for
[ __ ] sake
terrible idea mate I want my camcorder
back please I need to make youtubes
there's a guy with a light there and I
lost track of the other guys so this is
great I assume we have to go through
there oh my god no we're not going there
what the [ __ ] what do I do here it's he
like that's sexy that's real hot that's
real nice well I'm out of ideas
Oh actually I just got an idea I didn't
see this bye bye
[Applause]
later [ __ ]
I think we have to go down here ah [ __ ]
we alerted someone oh I can hide in the
water oh [ __ ]
ah [ __ ] this is cool how long can I hold
my breath [ __ ] just go just go
he's looking right at us dude
oh we did it we did it oh [ __ ] that was
close
I was a close one boys let's go in here
and lock the [ __ ] door yes [ __ ]
we're safe and a dish let's heal I
wouldn't even have to all right now but
all we have to do is find my Sony can't
oh my god yes
did he film something what is this keep
coming back earlier what the [ __ ] what
da [ __ ] indeed all right we're in the
cafeteria our as we call it in Sweden
Bamba if you're cool at least not if
you're [ __ ] Stockholm or Mama's
stupid I'm kidding I'm joking
ha ha ha ha everybody did a little gaffe
on you jab not about a feat tons yeah
blah all right then
battery someone say earlier oh yeah
blood live live live - all right doing
good
we're doing good more batteries any
batteries in here brush and the
batteries and better there's anybody
batteries hey it's a note sniff the
child sniff it
alright I don't think there's anything
wrong sniffing a chant don't quote me on
that though cuz I might be wrong on that
one I I haven't checked out the legality
of sniffing I'm serious all right I
don't want to go to jail for sniffing
I'll sniff a lot of things you know why
I don't I won't snitch oh hey yeah it's
a phone call no it's a [ __ ] banana I
don't know
oh no that's very bad that's really not
good at all they said you can't come
here you can't no okay
I have had better days I've definitely
had better days
[ __ ] me man that is bad that is real not
good oh no oh no oh [ __ ] oh hell no
for [ __ ] sake man - hello hello
is anyone out there that's that [ __ ]
call again okay from the toilet I don't
know they had toilet installed in the
bathroom am i wearing the headphones
correct because for me it sounds like
it's coming from the left okay any
batteries and the batteries anyone hey
Jesus Bob yeah alright let's take this
[ __ ] call there's a lot of rooms here
[Music]
here we go
hello everyone
top of the morning hello oh thank god
you're alive
I need you to stay calm we're going to
get you help we'll get you out of there
I want you to find a place to hide
someplace safe where you can remember
the taste of her kiss when you felt her
neck break you diseased [ __ ]
oh yes
did Jesus just lick me my god so so
sniffing is okay but licking licking is
not good got it got it duly noted all
right then
ah [ __ ] I'm sure it's fine I'm sheriff
I'd you just gotta think positive I'm
trying to think positive right now don't
close that door do not close it I'm fine
mine
shut that you better not die you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
don't lick me buddy yeah that's
disgusting
yeah ah [ __ ] that [ __ ]
[ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ] man close that
over man
yep not a problem oh my god it's so fast
I give me shimmers I didn't expect that
bye bye ash now [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah okay here
we go let's just run life's just run
don't look there you're looking back I
said don't look back oh hey it's a
locker hey let's go in here how nice
what
alright what the [ __ ] hey an ad we got
an ad everyone hey yes on the Peter Pan
chant how's it going buddy you look good
ah [ __ ] wrong door
that's alright I don't want to go in
there anyway
okay alright what did I say
what I [ __ ] say huh I guess I guess
we'll go here
no no hey yeah we have the microphone
thing I forgot about that okay
alright we're doing great doing so good
[Music]
alright we ran around the house we
managed to ran around the [ __ ] house
can i peek I don't what he's doing it's
boring me to death oh oh okay well now
we know where he is [ __ ] I'm making so
much noise with all this branches and
[ __ ] is it coming yep ah [ __ ]
that's fine
that's fine [ __ ]
I'm running for it
I'm [ __ ] going for it hey look
someone had a little snack are you doing
squeeze through your [ __ ] I'm fine
I'm fine I'm fine I'm fine don't worry
about our bye it's fine it's fine
everything's fine it's so fine it's so
fine it's fine err than my ass and
that's fine boy I'll tell you okay we
did it
excellent [ __ ] that [ __ ] that guy in the
[ __ ] back on that note we should end
that episode there thank you for the
support on these episodes I really enjoy
playing this game but I'm [ __ ]
pushing this as much as I can play leave
a like if you enjoyed watching and I'll
see you tomorrow on another episode
brass man